foreign
[Music]
at first I'm like literally shaking
those talks were so good how am I
supposed to follow that up but now I
don't do hashtag sportsball but that is
a layup where this is going to be great
so today's talk is going to be about
creating a design system for shiny and
our markdown which I've called hashtag
on brand I don't care if your company's
100 people or you have multiple clients
that you're trying to manage or just
yourself having a consistent and
cohesive UI
Greg might not hate it
um okay so this talk is coming from a
very selfish place I work with a lot of
clients where I'll look at their
websites and we'll see eight different
styled buttons all performing the same
action so I've kind of provided this um
like Scholastic uh compare what's
different in these photos of a bad and
good UI so uh in our don't do this
you'll see the top uh image and the
bottom image are different sizes why why
why why
um you have header text under both
images that are different sizes
different colors and different
opacities I'm literally getting hives
just thinking about this there's a bunch
here I'll leave that to you um these
slides are available for free
um
okay so Greg talked about incredible
rules but I am not a designer I'm a
programmer and I want rules that I can
govern my code by so I'm going to talk
about a design system and what is a
design system I got you it's a set of
rules constraints and principles
implemented in design and code
let's walk through an example here
a rule for color would be that it's you
have to pass a minimum color contrast
ratio for accessibility legibility if
you're going to put text on a background
I have to be able to read that
now constrain of that is going to be
these are my colors in my color palette
I am a millennial I love pink
um that this is going to be my color
palette for the rest of this talk and
that's also my guiding principle that
I'm just leaning in to loving these two
colors there's there can be a whole
conference itself in color theory and
why you should use green or whatever but
your principle can also just be as
simple as like I like Barbie
a little bit more uh informative here
shiny uh twist is an error message right
that's something really important that
you want to leverage to your users so
you're going to use a bright bold color
to denote that
um you'll see my background color and
the text color are legible enough that
you can read that text and then my
governing principle again is that red is
important and my eye is going to go
straight towards that
so this set of rules principles and the
constraints you're going to apply that
to all the things not just color spacing
how tightly are you going to pack those
things that Greg just taught us we
should put together do you want to let
them breathe do you want or should they
be really tight typography I overheard
at lunch uh one of like the most
incredible developers I know using a
PowerPoint slide deck and he was like I
just changed my font from the default
and now it looks like I have a brand yes
Type R yes yes Queen yes so all these
things important and we can use all of
these
components of our system to create
components and we're going to use those
reusable components inside page layouts
do you need a visual I do so here's
here's a component let's say it's a
button I'm going to apply my rules
constraints and principles to this point
to this button
now
in shiny land which we all are now we
can create a shiny module like a plot
that always lives with this button these
this code always
um lives together
and then finally I can put those
reusable uh modules inside my entire
page layout
so but I'm that pink
uh little cutie is always the same one
and we'll always be using that one all
the time and not eight different buttons
please
um so that takes us to a design kit it's
a collection of assets that contains a
set of design elements such as UI
components and styles
so
Joe did a ton of heavy lifting for me
yesterday thank you so much that I don't
have to talk about the basics of HTML
and Greg's hashtag no HTML no CSS
we where are my nerds at like yes we
want to learn these things
um so if you uh use tags dollar sign
button in the console and see what that
prints out that's your HTML that Joe was
talking about and this is the ugly
button that you get with vanilla HTML
but
she's reliable and faithful you get this
pointer when you scroll over it a thick
dark border and a gray kind of
background color
so that's a vanilla HTML button
but now we have an action button and
hurricane back to Joe's talk where you
have HTML and actions if x do y but what
Joe didn't talk about and Greg did was
that we also get CSS for free using
bootstrap we we're opting into a design
system thank you so much
um this button is already so much better
when I hover over it the background
turns gray how is this happening my HTML
element has classes that bootstrap is
going to leverage I urge you the best
way to learn this stuff is like play
with it break it and on the rest of my
talk is going to be the Journey of doing
that
to create my super extra button that I
am again I don't want to be put in a box
my buttons are going to be round I have
my pink tags and my pink background and
I call this button primary button so
we're going to make a package our code
Psy I could do this
um we're going to make a package and in
this package we're going to put all of
our assets but again this is the Journey
of our humble button so this is a root
directory of our package and we have an
R file for our button a CSS file and
then within an ins folder we'll have a
CSS file and a Javascript file because I
want to give you in this talk
pedagogically all the things you don't
necessarily need all these but you'll
have the code can play with it so let's
start in R
um
if there's one thing I want you to take
from this talk it's probably this slide
love that for you
um take a shiny input and then you can
use the function tagless append
attributes to put your own classes on
those HTML elements so it's like psych I
don't want to use BS lib or whatever I'm
going to use my own thing that I'm
making from scratch because I'm stubborn
I'm a developer
um and then we can use this wonderful
magical function HTML tools HTML
dependency
to which essentially says take that
JavaScript file and that CSS file and
now when you render that button you get
those for free along for the ride so now
I can just call primary button in my
quarto R markdown shiny app they're all
going to look and feel the same because
you get all that in your list object
chef's kiss beautiful so that's our so
that's our button
now for the CSS I really just want you
to focus on the first three lines here
um primary button was the class I gave
it that is this whole first three line
is in CSS is called a rule and in that
rule we're going to say apply to my
class of primary button the value with
the the value of background color white
or pink whatever in my case and here's
where you're going to lay out all the
CSS that you want for your button I am
not Greg I am not a designer this not
this talk is not to tell you what color
pink to look and why you hate the things
that you do that's your own Journey but
um I just want to give you the tools to
get up and running with this right and I
want you to also think about different
states in CSS so we have this concept of
pseudo selectors so not only am I
styling the button I need to think about
hovering I need to think about people
who are not using keyboard for
navigation and if they're using tab how
do you know where you are in the page
that's that's this Focus State you'll
get usually a heavy ring around it and
then disabled I can't click this button
what does that look like so I want you
to focus on the button itself but also
these different states
and then lastly is a JavaScript file I'm
not going over this it's kind of just a
flex that I can do this
um my button when you click on the
button it creates this little ripple
effect again slides play with it have
fun
but I just again wanted to show you you
can attach JavaScript and do do more
things there too
all right this is my Easter egg slide if
you click on this
you get my design kit which is a
markdown of all the elements here
um
and I don't have time for that you guys
all have computers I want to talk about
my two favorites in the kit
in the kit you're going to put the
output I need to see what it looks like
but also the code because if it's not
documented it doesn't exist so document
okay and why I want to show these off is
because they're so cute so when I hover
over this input it turns black and then
when I'm inside that input my label
turned pink and that was hard so please
let me have this moment another thing I
wanted to show is you can really have a
lot of voice in what I'm going to call
or what are called micro interactions
um
I for my tab panel here I wanted a
little swoop
I think that's really fun these little
micro uh animations are
a really Lively way to uh
to set up your slides but you don't want
to go too crazy and like
turn it into you know a PowerPoint Deck
with like animations all over the place
um so this is kind of like a take a
picture it'll last longer slide of
elements to include in your UI kit
navbar tabs buttons uh you know go ahead
smash that like button perhaps not
needed in an academic setting so you
don't need that in your presentation but
um other other elements here that you
can take away from this
uh and then lastly I uh this is all like
standing on the shoulders of giants here
who have written incredible books on how
to integrate JavaScript and CSS in HTML
in R and then I wanted to also plug this
incredible book refactoring UI which has
amazing visuals for like this why does
this bother me and this looks great
um and with that I just want to thank
everyone it's been so awesome to be here
and hanging out with everyone has been
incredible so thank you
foreign
[Music]